Jordan B.
Peterson
in your lectures,
you used the term postmodernism
interchangeably with cultural Marxism,
nihilism and moral relativism.
I wonder if you've considered or
heard alternative beliefs at the term
postmodernism is not necessary,
is necessarily always congruent on a one
to one scale with these other terms and
in some limited circumstances is positive.
Specifically the idea that wouldn't,
you'd use the term postmodernism to
vilify is by some others referred to as
pseudo modernism where as some would call
what you endorsed to not be modernism
but in fact Metta modernism post
millennialism or post postmodernism,
which unfortunately has a terrible name.
And then I have very brief just
definitions of those words.
If you need me to know,
as I said tonight,
you have to give the devil his due
and so we'll do that.
So yes,
there was a very large number of
ways of interpreting the world.
There's no doubt about that.
Um,
yes.
People use biased interpretive lenses
to as means of interpreting the world to
put their own
okay.
Priorities forward without necessarily
knowing that they're doing so and that
that can corrupt them.
And Society.
Psychoanalysts figured that out
way before the postmodernist.
So they don't get any credit for that.
Like really none.
MMM.
So it's useful to keep
those things in mind.
It's when they're put,
but it's when they're put forward
is absolute truth that disturbs me.
It's like,
yes,
people are probably racist.
They might even be implicitly racist,
although we don't know what that means
and we don't know how it's related to
their explicit behavior.
And we can't separate it from in group
preference or necessarily from reaction
to novelty.
So it's a tricky business.
You know,
and we don't know how to separate
stereotypical racial perceptions from
perceptual heuristics.
We don't know how to do that.
Cause you're always oversimplifying the
world because you're not smart enough to
live in the world as it is.
You have to oversimplify it.
So yes,
there are times when
postmodernism is useful,
are used it quite usefully tonight
to deconstruct postmodernism.
In fact.
So,
but,
but wait,
it's when it's turned into an absolute,
especially a moral absolute that it,
and when it aligns itself with Marxism,
it's like,
sorry guys.
No,
you don't like grand narratives.
You don't get to go there
while that's where you,
that isn't where you went,
that's where you came from.
You never,
you never left there.